hi so today we're going to take a look
at games which viewers have sent and I'm
going to try to keep my honest opinion
enough to give some information about
some interesting opening lines in to try
to you know to give some help to the
players who have sent their games small
also to our audience so the first game
what we know that both pairs were around
1200 and the guy who sent the game who
played with the black say the time
controls are 30 minutes and he says keep
in mind the game is probably bad as the
radicand the players was just under
1,200 okay the right kinda place is
quite okay so let's take a look at the
game efore e5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop
c4 Bishop c5 so we have the Italian on
the broad here why do you choose to play
like t3 and all right of 6 like the so
called Joko piano Jaco piano is the so
called slow line and now is the most
popular of the Italian which is D 3
which means slow play of course there is
like the the frost line of the past like
here Bishop before check and now on
Bishop d2 I like to play here aligned
with 94 this is my preference here
instead of Bishop take on D tone I takes
from D to D 5
the old theory now we can expand even
more but no need to go into some kind of
a you know theoretical display here also
there is like the gambit which I don't
remember exactly the name of this gambit
but the idea is that after Bishop takes
c3 instead of taken c3 and allowing
black to play D 5 D 5 is the gambit so
now you have two quite acceptable to put
it mildly lines for black these are the
old one with Bishop f6 rookie 197 take
for d6 which I have even played a couple
of years ago in active chess following
like a good theoretical line is called a
good victory and also the preferred one
from Anant 95 this is the other the
other line which is quite solid form for
black well it's here in this game white
played 93 so nice it tree is an old move
and it can be bad because it's like a
developing move it gives legs
flexibility in your opening choice but
quite curiously some new ideas can be
introduced and especially in this game
with 93 it was played a couple of maybe
a week ago
in a game Kramnik Anand in which kramnik
played in a very risky way he lost the
game against an old so what they paid in
this game was then I'll show you the new
ideas which I know that basically
correcting in in kramnik because they've
analyzed quite a few opening pushing
together so Dame introduced of 96 this
is what has been played here d3 and now
it's one of the very rare occasions in
opening lines when it you can play on
the fifth move a prophylactic move which
usually we try to say the young players
to avoid so my preferred move here is a
six well yh6 let me explain now there is
one line which is quite solid for black
but I think that it does not give them
some real winning chances so this has
been played many years ago by a
Bulgarian grandmas think of it was his
pet line so the main idea Bishop g5 h6
take Queen takes 95 Queen d8 c3 and here
of course their cup of the major
theoretical I think is 97 d4 Knight
takes from d5 like let me show you on
the broad like this was not or a black
has to to fight to prove that the
position is equal the other natural move
will be a six but after a six
when white lady for take Bishop a7
they have soy pushing in the center
which is at the cost of a dark square
Bishop which is important
the problem here is they can include
another useful move rook t1 which
prevents immediately black to play
Bishop g4 because there is Bishop a6
this threat now so this is too solid for
for my taste to play this with you know
it black so it's too solid the opening
line by white and also not very forms of
like castle B for visual basics Castle
also I think that it's very difficult
here to create some problems for white
that's why here my preferred choice and
of course this move has been known for a
long time ago is h6 and the idea just to
be more flexible just not Paul our
Bishop g5 and then see how white is
going to develop their pieces one thing
to know that on Bishop III you don't
exchange this bishop and opening the F
line for the white pieces which of
course with the bishop on c4 will give
them easy play on the half-open F file
but to play like we should be six anyone
on 95 to play d6 and you're not afraid
of the exchange of basics because you
take with a pawn and then you have a
very good central pushing you'll play
Bishop e6 who Castle you play d5 and the
pair Bishop really is not going to last
long and black has gained even a
half-open power for the rook on a 8n
deck has taken in the standard direction
the most commonly used towards the
center that a 7-pound takes well in just
a few occasions we takes taking the
country direction but these basically
when we win time now I mean the idea is
just to in time for faster development
but usually the standard decision is to
take towards the center now in this game
after d3 castle I'm not very fond of
this move because here I guess after
Bishop g5 probably you have to do a move
like Bishop e7 no because this pin can
be quite annoying now when you have
castle and why Cannot castle you can
approach the luxury to play a six in g5
because this will weaken you know quite
heavy
the kingside and white is not going to
castle on the on the kingside - so
Bishop g5 dis abstention they made
Castle d6 now h3o plus will move he
doesn't want to allow the Bishop g4
Bishop g5 of course is an option Bishop
g5 and then taking 95 c3 according to
already mentioned analyze H 3 H 6 now a
3 now a tweak
really I don't like much this move so if
I have to choose here probably I'll play
Bishop III like 6 more because on a 3 it
seems quite natural here for a black to
play Bishop Bishop e6 and you don't have
the B 3 square which is the natural move
in similar positions no this would be 2
because you want black to exchange and
take with the a pawn it does not make up
pawn structure better ok at least it
makes it decently nut and the 1/2 open
file can be used by your rook you don't
want to take usually on e3 only 6 when
your point has like a very easy play
then all the half-open F file like Queen
e89 th526 94 dabbling on the FI oh no
well in this game after a 3 they played
94 o 94 in my opinion they could have
taken they could have played another not
bad-looking move on it night a for know
this seems like quite alright decision
no here
Bishop e6 would be my preference but he
played 94b for not gaining much with b4
with before even I can play just to show
you I can even play here like night eggs
from the f3 Queen takes to an f3 Bishop
d4 now you have to put your Bishop on b2
now you can play toss from d2 but still
have to lose a little bit of time let's
say on d2 because it looks a little bit
monitor I can play Bishop e6 and it's
very hard to think that I can have here
any kind of problems no the Queen almost
never can go to g3 because Knight h5
will follow so the opening point you
still have before moving items e3 you
still have to move the loop from a1 and
it's not clear where this look has any
useful function I'm threatening now to
take on c4 and to make your pawn
structure not the best and I think it
black has a very good patient
he played Bishop b6 okay Bishop b2 we
already discussed it this probably is
not like the perfect position for the
bishop no probably still looks healthier
to play just Knight e4 kind of we should
be - rook e8 I don't know exactly what
is doing the ruku nyet my preference
here would be the move like Bishop e6 no
rook e8 it's kind of a note but the next
move that white plate is really just
very bad I mean everybody here in the
room you have no doubt about that and
after that the game becomes like a walk
in the park for for black he place 92 a
big big blunder I mean with this with
three interpretation marks and have the
knight takes on a three here they take
on h3 with a temple so he has an extra
an extra pound a terrible position here
on the on the King side and as a bonus
the bishop is on beat also the g5
squares accessible now I think now if he
here now I don't know
isn't it possible just to take me for
because I mean you can't chironji three
no you can't come on G three because
there is a bishop on basics so Knight
takes me four also makes sense no at
first sight no I mean it's kind of a
seems unpleasant no now instead of that
black community in a classic fashion d5
you know but there's no me not re not
not bad Bishop b3 now they took on e4
and okay now they saw that now they have
this tactical shot Knight takes me fall
and the game ended with a classical
checkmate on g2 wow this was like a very
interesting game
let's take a look ed the next one the
next one let's see if you have nose yes
we have some not so mr. brilliant with
white against well the players are round
the 1,000 little bit less white said
that this is like a uninteresting game
very interesting with a fan checkmate
and it has been sent by the player who
gave this interesting checkmate but
usually the guys who give interesting
checkmate dates and the games usually
the one who receives the very amusing
spec made I mean kind of forgets to send
the game always sometimes not sometimes
they said so let's see now
he 4595 Queen f6 well not everybody
knows that we should you know take care
not to introduce the Queen very early in
the game oh it's not like a reason Queen
f6 to to lose the game but it's a it's
an obvious opening mistake no because
why this is a mistake because now
developing the pieces white are going to
attack the Queen and because the big
difference between the relative value of
the minor piece in a queen is going to
win time and he's playing with white so
he's starting with a small initiative
and who is more time the difference in
development can become like this easy
factor d4 not that take
Knight takes from d4 well here many
other moves are possible new staff d4
Knight c3 you know trying to put knight
on d5 so you have to play it c6 then you
can develop this night on on a good
square Bishop c4 possible like no d4
especially to idea to take on to take on
d4 with a knight in my opinion is not is
not great because as I see it we can get
immediately the the Scotch the scorching
a good version for black because here
maybe the station just to play Bishop c4
but on here instead of t5 Bishop c5 kind
of a looks normal no and when I'm
talking about the the Scotchman we can
get this vision which probably all of
you know if they don't know okay let me
show you because I've played a lot of
out of the Scotch so this is one of the
lines here of course they have 96 main
line tool but Bishop c5 Bishop e3 well
probably you know that 196 is considered
better just first to play the
intermediate move because okay the
threat on f6 kind of a makes white not
to develop their piece in the most
natural way although there is a very
safe and game for white which starts
with Queen f3 it's not an applied to end
game they can play Queen g6 but this is
some kind of a concession know so
getting back to our patient after Queen
f6 and we play it c3 well we have the
one which could have occurred in the
game no no of course after Bishop c5 you
are not obliged to play with you can
play Knight if driven you know just
playing with this night back in forward
and backward it's not the kind of a
opening play which really should be
followed c5 really weakens a lot of
squares it not help develop it on the
contrary now the bishop on f8 starts
feeling a little bit sad no and now in
this Knight goes to b5 gen I can go to
see it we and d5 with the tempo no so
obviously a mistake well he ate surprise
me at least why the night went not on d5
with a clear in quite honest threat 97
no but he went on f3 usually you try to
play the most active modes no this is
like a quite natural thing
93 and of course then it will not be
possible to play night seek because
there is an immediate threat no not so
easy to be to be parried this threat no
because if you play like let's say Queen
six probably well I can even sacrifice
this no problem Queen six I can play
Bishop at four walls even the endgame is
better even but I can probably want
sacrificing I'm not very sure that
you're going to trap my knife but might
be five obvious it looks like the best
move I mean I have no doubt about that
and of course when this move even I can
play Queen d5 so many moves well Knight
f3 is not the most ft 296 okay Bishop d3
Bishop d6 well take keep developing
pieces which is not bad and they are
ready to to reply on 93 with 97 no here
and here is the earth 97 they kind of a
seduced put the knight on the edge of
the ball
oh this usual is not a very bright idea
why it's obvious because from here
the knight guess basically only one
possible square yes actually two but
okay let's not make the knight a very
sad piece if we counted he has also the
GA square because this was not his idea
to go forward and backward and you know
to make life kind of image that he's
some kind of a crazy night which I don't
know exactly what he's doing
so now Bishop g5 anyway now he ain't
a'no in a region when we starting making
some big mistake so if they have played
like 9:27 they had more more like
available squares you not to put their
pieces for example if they have played
here 97
when they play Bishop here where at
least they can play the Queen here no
only six makes it they still can play it
here after after Bishop g5 all okay I
still don't like the night matrix but
away this move queen g6 is just a big
blunder because here we have E 5 now for
some reason it was not played but after
E 5 there will not be a fan checkmate
probably have to resign yes yeah yeah
it's possible to take the beetle pawn
yeah now I still have doubt the opening
choice because after 92
I'm heading another trade no like 94 and
probably this machine is quite
suspicious because the Queen you know
this is like the main problem with the
Queen when it starts roaming you know
and in the opening in here it starts on
the second move
so it basically at the first possible
moment because when you are with black
or white the first possibility to move
the Queen as of the second move so here
they didn't lost even attempt oh no
immediately fire fighting with the Queen
so after Queen g6 if I've obviously wins
a piece no but they followed this all
advice which sometimes is not true
so in in quite a few cases to its it
says that the threat is stronger than
its execution well here it's an
exception the execution of e5 was quite
strong but still they played Queen e2
threatening if I've no well now black
were not in the mood anymore to give
material and they played queen h5 so no
more pieces for for rights of the threat
really and now well yeah now they have a
threat so Queen each item is quite a
good response to Queen e2 in the in the
area that you're creating a threat or do
you could have execute immediately and
now I'm creating at the credits this
Bishop take one edge - no you take and I
take on GFI winning opponent okay so now
we are entering into the tactics nine
three well they don't pay attention and
probably they should get played here no
I think no you take I take you well
still I have you know f4 still the 1986
is kind of a not my favorite piece but
okay
I mean this game could have been yes
let's see oh yes 94 yeah exactly you are
absolutely right
so 94 is the common theme from the also
from the more gambit now I'll show you
to zoom here how this team also now not
fun anymore because you're getting
checkmated no yeah immediately so yeah
this was again with quite a few so the
team which I mean from the Mora so just
let me show the same team you showed
here so there is like the moral gambit
of the Sicilian and there is like one
line I used to play from time to time
not always IKEA
here let's say castle Queen c7 Queen e2
and now I think 94 no with idea if you
move and if you move the rook Bishop c5
and if you play here you can get this
small present know which is something
which could have happened here and
probably you should have the same game
sent by black now having a a fun moment
by the way no found for blacks with a
castle still they have this threat but
away this time might be five so taking
care of this threat probably without
even knowing well the other one could
have been executed no so now Bishop
takes on h2 is still possible now they
played f6 here and f6 really is punished
by Bishop taken h6 now to piece on the
attack and even if we go like let's say
here with the bishop now I can go only
three now so I don't see how you can
make some kind of a nutri snow you can
push away the done item be fire they can
go back but okay I'm not going to get
checkmate on h2 and probably the end of
the game now here it was simply because
he taken a six-night takes from d6 and
now here's an extra piece so let's see
what they considered fun this sorry
why Bishop on f7 this is an ITEX tune if
7 is like an extra rookin completely
reasonable push on Bishop f7 he's a kind
of a he's trying to take the Queen maybe
with 95 now the queen is not tripe
actually because she can run away hmm
yeah neither 7 is winning yet we have an
extra routine the game is over but
Bishop f7 e 5 queenie for now comes
bishop GA with a threat knight of seven
although the knight of seven could have
been executed earlier no now of course
he could have taken he could have taken
with with the king no but he preferred
to get small checkmate well this seems a
little bit like a rigged game so we have
some doubts about this one okay okay
let's let's go to another one with
probably better players this one does
not get any kind of comment so I'm going
to okay he says current game okay here
we have a game which they have more
rating and they have more not so hi
everyone I'm Vito from Brazil I really
enjoy watching please find attached one
of my games patches calm it was a quick
one only 20 moves he doesn't say the
time control he was with black and let's
analyze this game and see what happened
so he for g5 Bishop c4 well the play was
of this Bishop on the on the serial
maybe it's better to be done when the
ponies on d6 become whether the pawn is
still only 7 and the ponies of d7
usually right here pair with black
because this capping plate
with many kids against me in some
friendly game I play a six-night six a
six and then I you know play against
this bishop so this is like a common and
this Bishop usually is not very active
and then I play d5 and I defend my
Center usually I develop my pieces like
that with black against Bishop c4 now
Knight six a3 not really needed but okay
I have six d3 g 6o the fianchetto of the
bishop is possible he of course I can
also include f4 h3 Bishop g7 C 3 now at
this moment before playing c3 I don't
see like a threat you know because with
a treat at least he guarantees that this
Bishop your stay on this you know so
maybe it was time to start you know
developing pieces because after c3 have
a castle kill play d5 you take F good
position in the center black so maybe
it's time to develop the pieces I think
it's even better just to take a look
from his point of view because he wasn't
black know
and he played quite decent so Castle
Knight if to e6 know d5 also gives him
good play d5 Knight takes from d5 and
then you play Knight b6 the bishop goes
by five with a temple now so obviously
white has lost a lot of time in the
opening so no doubt about it he prefers
to have like a good pawn Center well
this could have been answered
although white position does not allow
this luxury play them but maybe they
could have played here a 5 noe 598
well they can play also 95 but I still
will play you know d4 on this now they
can play here and people well of course
this is a good position for black
because they can immediately start now
harassing the center because they have a
better development yeah I mean it's like
a choice between different tables here
after caso d5 you also were so
I mean no doubt about that well maybe
here there is no definite targets for
white sake preferred to go that so
Bishop here Ruki 8 but you have less
space no in the bishop on a to probably
is not going to be very useful Bishop g5
Bishop f5 logical move what I found
sorry did he wants to lure the night for
example NATO and had to play Bishop e6
which is okay he can play it Amir 3 but
okay Bishop a5 has the the advantage it
it kind of makes the night on b1 to
wonder how it's going to be develop and
you don't want that you have lost time
in the opening and black played very
natural moves to play a 493 maybe it's a
little bit too much no so d4 which is
followed by c4 quite logical rule q1
well maybe it was time you know to play
92 in to try to play B should be one I
know that maybe he's having some hopes
of the bishop or NATO but it's time to
be realistic and just to try to exchange
this bishop because it's not very good
no now rook e1 cost time and I think
that white patient cannot afford such a
luxury no Queen b6 it looks ok not the
only move they could get plate even take
take we in like 10 Queen b6 now and then
we create we attend market Queen b6
bishop take on f6 Bishop take on f6 of
course after Bishop f6 and no need in my
opinion here to calculate like Queen
takes and b2 because okay stew is not
clear how you're going to defend here
here okay now it's not clear but it was
not a bad idea to defend no I mean with
Queen c1 or Queen Queen d2 well graph
the Queen e2 I can move a piece so
probably Quincy one now this is like a
very bad position I mean no doubt about
that
I can just play Bishop d3 rookie - do I
have something first let me think
I'm neither a 5k plane ID - no but the
position is is dubious so but he should
have played Quincy one I mean no doubt
but after 92 he just gave the pawn just
for free and almost everything no a for
now the ponies hanging he played Bishop
g2 but could have taken no because he's
taking everything no we played Bishop g2
here to concede three now you can use
the pin in my opinion no because the
rook is hanging he played here and
always starting gave everything and
maybe because of this check it kind of
feels like fun but away this was like a
difference between the players although
the player with with black has less
rating but kind of tell that he plays
like more natural chess now in a better
quality so let's take a look this game
okay let's take a look of someone who
says hello to Ben fine god he liked his
video although we are going to take a
look not not Ben and he's from
Netherlands in his word playing the
black and he was playing the Sicilian
okay let's take a look at this Cillian
c5 Knight f3 d6 d4 well this line I
remember it has been played by an old
international master in Bulgaria he even
used to play it like that used to play C
5 c4 yeah this was his favorite line no
no after this time you try to take
control the dark squares now you've
tried to play Bishop g4 96 g6 Bishop g7
or it's a solid system why it has sounds
static and the cap is not as bad as it
may look the major problem is you're
weak in the d4 square and you're not
getting something in return like that
the corresponding square d5 cannot be
weakened so that
palm only seven can go to sixteen
defendi square by the way it's not only
bad news so you're getting some space
like I told you I prefer here to play
like with Bishop g4 and then Isaac g6
and then if you take my wish I'm going
to exchange it and I'm going to play
Bishop g7 and then 97 96 97 take good
control of the dark squares and my play
obviously will be mainly on the Queen
side no here he placed 96 and 93 96 well
the following the following move is an
obvious mistake I mean no doubt about
that 95 I think that the pawn can be
taken off it's a solid extra pawn and
when you have a central pawn which
sacrificed you you you gara have and
just remember that very strong reasons
not to take a central pawn and these are
not my words this I think was even a
phrase by names which are quite good and
play who gets contributed a lot of
things to chess he's written some
excellent books like my system so a
central pawn is a very important pawn so
you should take it if there is nothing
you know imminently an imminent danger
now so he didn't took only fall he
played six which is also not that
because today still they're losing time
so she plays like a typical opening
mistakes a second move with a with a
piece in the opening now the Queen goes
to f6 well I prefer the bishop to heaven
f6 but if you have not taken a a pawn
you can keep everything alive because
after ninety five so you don't have know
you can even play here 97 that is not
like a natural move now if you prefer to
take the pawn or what he played here so
he took with the Queen at six key the
Queen f6 is a little bit you have to
lose a little bit of time later on
Bishop d3
well it looks more natural
basically to play Bishop only - no but
maybe let's take a look maybe with
Bishop e2 he was a little bit too
worried about Queen g6 now
I should not have been if I have to be
on it because I can play all I want to
say nice for the guy it's not so good so
can i sacrifice killable I think I can
not very sure how good it is because
okay this like a better version of a
have a central pawn so I can have some
kind of a compensation maybe not big no
maybe not big wandering here to play B 3
B should be too we play d3 in here and
d4 I can have some play for the poor no
because of the situation of the Queen
yeah it's kind of I don't like most like
Bishop d3 I mean it's kind of feels
unnatural but his main preoccupation was
not to lose a pawn well if you were so
anxious about the point he could get
played on d3 no I don't see anything
wrong with such a normal move no d3
anyway also you can play here like g3
although it seems kind of artificial now
and I don't like it so be careful with
with the timing chest even in close
position they say that there the temples
may not be so important but in my
opinion they are always important so if
you can save temple just try to do it so
Bishop d3 Bishop e7 caso 94 so basically
this move I don't see the point of this
move it's helping in my opinion white I
can take on d4 and then just try to
develop my piece I really not sure for
example let's take a look if I take
obviously he was wanting to take with
the Queen well now I can if I don't want
to give anything I can play like Queen
e2 Queen c2 but then I'll have a little
bit inconvenience to develop my pieces
but I can play here if you take this
pawn I'm not very sure that this
position you're giving me some tempo so
ok let's say I play d3 and you have to
give me more tempo slow to play here I
can play
Bishop III if you take here I can check
and I have compensation here B fact is
not possible because of will be one
Bishop d7 also so you have to play King
f8 and although I have sacrificed a
couple of poems I kind of can play D for
him you have some problems Q so not very
happy if a [ __ ] p2 is not a good move
Bishop deed
he too is giving the pair of Bishop a4
Kieffer if I like I can take only two
and I prefer to play this position with
with black I have a pair of bishops no
weak spots so why not no I prefer way he
took on f3 which also is quite solid no
Bishop goes to f3 not like the perfect
patient but after E 5 they are probably
they started to make like strategic
mistakes so here when the spawn
structure is like that you have one move
which you just have to do with the hand
I mean without thinking much
so in this pawn structure when the black
pawns ie 5 D 65 what the thing is the
move that White has to do which piece
you want to exchange you want to change
the bishop now this one and you want to
exchange it because of a then your pawns
will be on white and you have a dark
square Bishop and it's like good news
for you no then you play d3 then you
exchange invisibly ok it cannot be worse
I mean you always will have from static
point of view at least you know
something to hold on so I prefer Bishop
g4 but they play d3 g6 they avoid it
just playing Bishop g4 just Bishop d2
castle and b4 yes ok but they are
playing you know with the bishop on f3 I
don't know how their play is going to
progress like b6 now quite curious
tricky to quit with the b-pawn know it
kind of feels like you should take with
a deep on because then gives you because
there is not no nice in the pigeon also
there is no landing on the square d 5 so
it makes the D file a half of
now with a target on d3 No so it kind of
feels logical to play detections if I
beat X 25 kind of lacks meaning in my
opinion Bishop d3 but the way this kind
of a close tax is probably a more
difficult it depends on the level so
rook b8 h 3 now still you know Bishop g4
is waiting to be played here Bishop d7
a4 so what I see here it probably white
is waiting till he moves his Queen and
black plays Bishop take on h3 because
this is going to happen at the end now
if you just keep your Bishop on f3 and
the Queen on f6 probably this is like a
threat so here he played Queen at 4 this
move is a little bit I understand the
meaning he wants to push the pawn laughs
I but it's kind of a Viking play Bishop
d2 I don't understand much the meaning
of this move a5 a6 rugby one well like I
told you it was destined to happen so
now I can play rook takes would be one
which was not played let let's take a
look if it's true because okay sometimes
we can miss something and Bishop take on
h2 you know yeah I mean if you wait too
much for something no it will occur yeah
it was possible in my opinion well he
can at least you can play here like
Queen d7 Oh attacking the pawn so maybe
it's not as as dangerous as it may seem
yeah he's having here some counter play
on the bone so I I don't seem to to be
able to create here something on the on
the King site immediately at least I
don't see how I can do it immediately
yeah maybe not yeah probably
he played Bishop h4 okay not giving the
the B file probably a right decision no
Bishop d2 now the Queen goes back now
now these maneuvers a little bit [ __ ]
rook b6 so basically after not doing
much he is giving away the strategic
initiatives and our white is having
pressure Bishop g5 well from static
point of view this is not bad no because
he's trying to exchange the bishop which
most of his pawns on dark squares the
question is is it good tactically
because if I take and take on a six on
on d6 I'm taking a couple of points you
can take on h3 but this does not seem to
to bother me too much now so so probably
here if I just take take here take can
you take this is probably already a bad
position oh I can include here such a
move no Quincy one now you you don't
have squares for the Queen you don't
want to exchange quiz because then you
have a an endgame pawn down and if you
play this move now I take the pawn in
you have to go back with the bishop and
I kind of doubt that you have you know
for the pawn but rook takes one eighty
six and now rock-beetle well now they
are getting active route g3 or okay - I
kind of feel that this this book here
may have some problems anyway they stop
harassing this rook let's see let's see
this is a good phase of the game so
Queen B one yeah this is what I was
watching here now why not Bishop d1 it
kind of felt a bishop d1 is the end of
the journey for the rook all right they
played Queen b3 which basically is not
threatening the rock no oh it will be
turning when you start threatening the
LightSquared Bishop but it gives a
little bit of time Bishop back for now
Bishop g4 uh-huh so they are playing for
this probably wrong technical idea
because now I can create some thread
toward the King because you see how they
keep all of his pieces they don't pay
attention to the open and threat which
is like a feature quite common so they
here now if you take with a poem they
want to play Queen h4 so at least they
are guaranteed you know a continuous
check probably not more know if you have
to be if we have to be honest I don't
believe that in this position okay okay
I took here yeah you play here and can
you go somewhere with this rook I don't
see okay if I play g3 you take they can
you aspire for something more I don't
believe me it looks like a draw to me
look alright okay took here and now
Bishop take here with a threat Queen g5
now I also don't see anything else then
then the repetition now if a if I take
on h3 and I defend the pawn the pawn on
I mean what I see is this I mean I take
you give me check up like when you are
taking G to know if you play here you
play you play here and I defend no draw
but they play after if some reason now
traitor in checkmate in one which of
course is not the end of the world well
I mean this was like full of mistake I
could play Knight as Queen a tuner
defending and I don't see checkmate no
check
here well now if you go away I'll have
to play G phone oh well yeah maybe maybe
you can play with the temple yeah
attacking the rook yeah yes okay now
you're threatening checkmate and you're
taking the rope here so maybe maybe not
as it seems so can i play another move
well he's threatening checkmate so I
don't have many options no rook f2 like
he played which will float or queen 8o
on Queenie too well but I can play King
H to know so check I can play here no he
still has this year still has this
temple move no here threatening
checkmate and threaten in the rock yeah
bad news
so Luke f2 Bishop e3 anyway now it was
not needed to to miss a rain I check
making one after Queen e2 but let's see
of course you can go here because I'll
take and you still got checkmate no I
mean this will follow with this so let's
take a look at this
King f1 now you take here and I just I
don't believe it
if I run on the dark rice you can give
me checkmate because usually the Queen
in the bishop they need to control boy
that ball type of square so let's check
the two lines first our checking after
but if I take here what's happening so
you're giving me checkmate I don't see
I'm just running better way they should
have like a strong attack now because
you need like and the material is
basically equal oh no so yeah probably
this it's not babe yeah no this dislike
a bad position oh I mean yeah I can play
here and yeah this is bad so let's try
the other one he should take here to
take him away this is also like a free
attack no I mean
play here and then check yeah this is
looks bad no I guess that's picking up
pause and then the H pawn is fast well
this one may give some counter play but
yeah this game was from static point of
view I was not understanding what is
happening but when they came to tactics
they were more inventive and they really
didn't pay attention
why to the back threat let's see the one
so I'm not sure if you guys are still
accepting games from the unit or you
were accepting I'm Luis and I'm from
Indonesia my online which is about 1900
and this was played with a long time
control of 5 + 8 minutes now okay enough
and we play it over the board so this
was I was with Dwight let's take a look
this gaming let's put white here now he
45 93 96 d4 and now we have a very
modern opening line the so-called
Kalashnikov so this is different than
the specially cooked in some details
know even the the the major protagonist
of the space because we start to play
this new version and it has you know the
special name Colossus with EFI Emil so
if I have 95 d6 well no the difference
is that I can play 93 so there is this
line 93 a 6 here and on b5 95 now it was
not played in 1895 but also compared to
specially cover when you get the knight
on c3 and on f6 here I can play the
solid c4 no ok white always have like a
small dent to the pollo game black if
there especially in the system also no
they usually use that the knight is not
on f6 so when they push away this night
they try this ideas with Bishop e7
Bishop g5 now if they can exchange the I
squared Bishop because the pawn
structure defines if you prefer to have
the dark squared Bishop exchange know
the
then the bishop on e6 is taking care of
the of the some squares like d5 but okay
he always white them has to be careful
about the square default now 93 was
played here 93 96 and we are different
more water we come to the [ __ ] of not
now after Bishop g5 they don't play
obviously one of the opponent or maybe
birthday were not they're aware of the
the theory so is there playing b5 in
going to the specially goof which was
used by the world champion in his last
and famous match with for beyond Khurana
and okay I had a book about the first
nickel and that's why I said I call this
book the easiest Sicilian because
probably in the strategic ideas of this
fashion ago fast are the most
straightforward it the easiest to learn
and Carson has played it before and he
had like this young and very talented
Grandmaster in his analyzing team dubov
which played a lot of a lot of specialty
group so he has prepared technical very
well and Fabiana went to a one very
interesting pigeon with 95 on the
seventh move and he got interesting foot
positions but probably they were if we
have to be honest a little bit easier to
play with black so although in some
games can get promising position but
they are quite complex from aesthetic
point of view not easy to play now so as
a result he didn't have the points he
would have expected so probably this was
like one of the more simple or burning
in the last World Championship match the
station occurred because when he played
with Bishop b5 against 96 he also you
know kind of get into very good opening
preparation so which was also
demonstrated by Carson in in the world
blitz championship when he played the
scheme he played in the first game
against Corona and scored a very good
for victory and he even mentioned this
game is one of his best against one how
on the black site of the Sicilian Bishop
b5 g6 the same scheme Fabiano played
with him in the first game
and could have lost the first game
although he fought very hard and managed
to escape with a draw so now instead of
technical Bishop e7 well Bishop e7 has a
problem 2094 now Bishop take on f6 we
are going to have a bad bone structure
in the night is going to land on e3 and
black does not pay any attention so
maybe white because of that are quite
happy of this game so h6 really not
paying attention to the positional
threat we should take one f6 well little
bit and on Bishop f6 they didn't pay
attention to a tactical threat now so
instead of getting some very bad bounce
back to they're just giving up a pawn
okay my take on c8 possible move not the
only move all right
logical not take 95 check here c3 so the
opening phase is over we have a solid
texture palm and as a compensation black
has a worse position like they used to
say when I started playing chess so say
you've lost the pole but it's a
composition you have a terrible position
so something like that so here I here
we're not talking about terrible patient
but the patient is really like a nut
encouraging one so it's like the worst
version of the special I have seen so
your pawn down no pair of bishops no
control of the dark squares whatsoever
and you guys like eternal knight on d5
which basically is help with an extra
pawn so here we should be to g6 castle
Bishop g7 now this is like normal move
Queen b3
a temple move well this always a good
sign when you start playing are
developing moves here he's putting the
Queen on b3 and he's going to put the
rock on the one with the tempo and of
course because there are different type
of bishops each movement of the pawn the
points which are on white gives more
target so when you push for example b5
is going to follow it a4 main Keys
Bishop is working and the one on g5
basically is pretending to work so he's
just faking that he's working he's not
doing anything no because there is
nobody on this deal now
so b5f oh no this is really trying to to
make the bishop like a useful piece
because a4 is the move you should do
with the hand know instead of f4 no he
should have taken a knife oh I mean no
doubt about that Knight a5 don't really
get this move Queen 83 bishop each wow
this is terrible I mean I don't know why
they are so afraid I've taken a fall
either with the bishop or with upon the
way I mean you should take here let's
let's you know um the previous move here
so we should take on a throne oh well
maybe maybe he was afraid now I see it
enough g3 and some some taken but I
don't see how how is that going to
happen let's see g3 I play here so how
are you going to take on on f7 I mean if
you jump with an item going to pay off
the seventh of not really clear for me
no way this is much bad even if this is
working I mean playing like that you
know giving away you know more and more
material is terrible so here and now
they state collecting everything no now
you're basically lost because in even
here I don't know why I mean I I just
have taken on a six no basically you're
playing without a flag no I will not
have taken on kanji for this night
because I don't see this night what is
doing I can take here let's say you take
here and now
no maybe no need to take a defect with
the Queen to let him like Group B a B
should take be a normal move no Queen a7
looks also quite help you know getting
to d4 because the visual cue is really
asking for some unpleasant questions so
Bishop take on c4 take quintal insects
here
and now follows a combination let's take
a look because this makes the game
interesting rook takes on f7 just like
the following team about the Romantic
era he tries to play here in this style
is it working yeah I don't have to take
you and look at one I don't know why he
didn't paid King g7 now the King g7 when
you give me check with the Queen you
don't have access to the g6 pawn no
Sookie I should play King g7 and just
ask you to show me if well I still yeah
let's let's take a look if you play here
and I okay not here this was like what
happened in the game like play here I
give you a check no this one is hanging
okay now I play here maybe look f7 no
but rook e1 know you a queen of sound
checkmate yeah yeah I didn't I didn't
see that at all yeah so he calculated
like a force checkmate no yeah but hey
can I interrupt this no I can't because
he's taking with a check now
yeah abso maybe he saw this this first
line oh look at one yeah so then then
yeah I don't see how I run out of this
because he faced tonight at 6 wait let's
try a little bit if I play wow I play
here you play check say here then you
take here I I know that this should be
lost but 95 is a double check which is
the problem no this is a big problem
yeah I mean I can play Queen B 8 because
95 is a double check let checkmate
yeah probably lost now in the game it
followed queen g6 here
well ok 7 and and checkmate yeah well
this game not much of a resistance
because they were giving up almost
everything
many of the games yet like big blunders
but still Matos I hope that it was
helpful just to take a look and try to
give some advice the openings although I
repeat most of the games were having
some leg but there were quite a few
interesting moments quite a few
interesting tactics and some checkmating
moments so ok if they keep descending as
games we're going to take a look because
this is the main idea so thanks for
being here with me and take a look at
the games and till the next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]